on a lancé sur instagram une initiative
destinée précisément aux jeunes qui
votent pour la première fois mot-clic
premier vote les jeunes envoient une
vidéo de 15 secondes où il pose une
question aux leaders politiques ou aux
partis alors pas très soir eu cette
bonne idée d'inviter trois de ses jeunes
hier ici à l'extérieur de radio-canada
carrément et simplement pour par les
élections
mathieu johann in isabelle première fois
vous avez l'occasion de voter vous devez
regarder la campagne électorale de façon
différente cette fois-ci qui or quatre
ans mathieu oui c'est évident parce que
cette fois ci on s'attend à ce qu'il est
parti nous donne plus d'attention vu
qu'on peut léser les donc il devrait
miser sur nous théoriquement est ce que
vous trouvez qui mise un peu sur vous
jusqu'ici vous dis qu'il faut vraiment
mais en même temps c comprenant puisque
il y en plus c'est profiter profiter
politiquement de miser sur des
générations plus populeuse qui va plus
c'est aux dernières élections
39 % des gens sont allés voter mais
c'est à nous afin de place joannie noël
vous êtes souverainiste et là vous
hésitez comme beaucoup de souveraineté
sur québec entre le bloc évidemment et
le npd dans votre corps et oui est parti
et le retour de gilles duceppe me laisse
un peu froide en riant pourquoi et pour
moi pour casser ces impôts castet cas
qu'on quitte on quitte pour de bon on
part pour revenir au parc on revient on
al impression qu on hésite on est comme
posture son avance vers la souveraineté
où sont ces jeux sans parler comme ça
pour moi ils sont une idée claire
puisqu'il ya pas présentement dans le
le bloc québécois alors je pense je
penche un peu oui côté npd beaucoup à
cause d'un jack layton mais loyers plus
là
j'aimais beaucoup ses idées que jamais
l'homme mais j'aime peut-être un petit
peu moins un personnage de thomas se
moquer alias tom c'est ainsi donc
j'hésite et comme j'étais indécise
encore ouais ouais
isabelle les vagues 19 ans oui qu'est-ce
qui vous êtes qu'est ce qui vous a
marqué dans cette première moitié de
campagne
ce qui m'a marqué dans cette fois-ci de
campagne c'est difficile de marquer
parce que je trouve que comme à toutes
les campagnes électorales il ya beaucoup
de mots en l'air qui disent donc de
promesses de candidat qui ont la langue
de bois comme toujours les candidats qui
changent d'idée par exemple qu'on peut
penser à tomtom
mulcair qui étaient contre l'epa plaine
et qu'il a balancé pour selon certaines
conditions
c'est un exemple parmi tant d'autres
donc moi ce qui m'a marqué c'est
justement qu'est ce à quel point c'est
encore pareil comme à toutes les fois
qu'ils vous inspire dans la campagne
actuelle le plus confiance pas plus
confiance
je dirais c'est elizabeth may donc celle
qui va les chercher dans un premier vote
de votre vie ben moi je dirais que shia
certaine à savoir si je vais voter ou
non donc je représente cette partie des
jeunes qui n'iront pas voter
et selon moi pas parce qu'ils ont aucun
intérieur la politique ou qui s'en
foutent clairement mais parce que ils se
sont pas représentés ou ne croient pas
en la politique actuelle en le système
le parlementarisme vous ce point
discours
mathieu qui jette pas du tout dans ce
discours là vous aurez un mois en fait
le chef tient sur plus confiance gérer
que c'est stephen harper je trouve que
c'est un homme sérieux droite il peut
pas le prendre des décisions
impopulaires même sont bonnes park par
exemple l'abolition du
ma feu où là aussi l'âge de retraite
mais par contre la plateforme qui
m'inspire le plus c'est cette spéciale
du parti libéral vous êtes oui
exactement
j'aime beaucoup c'est que le bilan des
conservateurs par contre je sens que les
gens ont soif de changement puis c'est
légitime c'est ça le changement je pense
que c'est le parti libéral qui nous
révèle deux sérieux donc donné du lustre
à la corse moyen entre autres et donc
vous hésitez encore les libéraux et les
conservateurs
qu'est-ce qui sera déterminé à vous dans
votre choix il reste quelques semaines
10la le débat acclama bon ben ça tombe
bien on a présenté la semaine prochaine
je vais le regarder
donc le débat là vous allez vous allez
voir qu'ils qui va vous cherchez le plus
ouais vraiment parce que quand on répond
à une question
on peut et on peut répondre par écrit et
par vidéo par son site internet peu
importe mais répondre face à face avec
un contact humain aux yeux dans les yeux
je trouve qu'il ya quelque chose qui se
passe il ya un déclic qui fait que tu
s'ils croient qu'ils croient juste pas
pour moi c'est l'extase ou dernier
l'élément vous êtes jeunes qu'est ce que
vous aimeriez entendre davantage comme
thème dans cette campagne électorale
comme jeune ben je pense que le thème de
l'économie est déjà omniprésent mais
vous voyez que que c'est le bon terme
sélection donc je voudrais prennent en
compte plus mais c'est un peu
superficielle que vendra frais qui qui
rend plus dans le concret dans les
détails ce serait que la population n'en
tire pas nécessairement à ce débat là
parce que ça me coûte très technique
mais je pense que c'est la pureté vous
c'est la question sur les immigrants de
parler un peu oui migrent sur toi mais
qu'est ce qui se passe en syrie est ce
que monsieur applaudit aussi récemment
que on allait oui on accepter mais on
veut prendre des minorités soient
ethniques ou de liberté religieuse
pour moi c'est un non catégorique le jeu
on devrait pas faire renaître une
sélection du grand puits sur texte passe
en syrie
je peux pas croire que on en est rendu
là vous dirais qu'on n'ouvre les gros
pulls en maille ben oui l'allemagne
l'ont fait puis se retrouve un peu dans
le bordel présentement mais c'est pas
parce que quelqu'un l'avait qui se
retrouve qu'on va se retrouver
nécessairement dans le bordel je pense
que oui faut ils sont des barèmes mais
je vois pas pourquoi faudrait est très
pressé ses barèmes là à 2 2 deux groupes
de personnes 10 bis comme ça je le vois
pas besoin non plus vu de la région ont
mené à court terme ça peut fonctionner
mais à long terme pour rétablir la paix
si comme la moins conséquent même des
gens imerys a peut être toi si justement
on se connaît pas encore les voit qu'on
ne s'est pas désintégré il ya des coups
à un pays avec ces gens là c'était sympa
se débloque vous venez de faire depuis
quelques secondes
c'est le débat qui a lieu depuis
plusieurs semaines donc vous vous
représenter un courant légitime encore
une fois vous aussi on verra il ya des
choix différents que les politiciens
propose en terminant donc vous n'êtes
pas sûrs d'aller voter vous est sûre
vous votez oui
l'atelier prend l'addition je pense que
déjà prise mais l'elysée les pauvres
mais je dirais pas que j'irais pas mais
je pense que je dirais pas très bien à
moins que quelque chose - qui est
quelqu'un un chien fou un paradis mais
jamais jamais pourquoi vous donnez pas
sur votre tapis je crois pas on les
parlementaires c'est fondamental c'est
bien joannie vous allez atteindre la
dernière minute après les débats choisi
ouais mais c'est son château
j'aurais palois charles et moi j'ai des
comptes à ok vous moi je pense que je
suis décidé pour le parti libéral mais
j'ai j'aime beaucoup les bilans du parti
conservateur je trouve qu'ils ont été un
très bon gouvernement mais des fois il
faut passer à autre chose ça fait quand
même huit romans de je pense qu'ils sont
là donc je pense qu'il faut changer un
peu la mentalité des gens qui dirigent
et c'est bon d'avoir un coup de main je
vous remercie à vous trois une bonne fin
de campagne
bossi il reste pas mal de semaines
encore merci